[Musique]
bienvenue à l'hôpital de mire ballet
premier centre de traitement de lakovic
19 en haïti
cet hôpital situé à une heure et demie
de route de port au prince est un des
mieux équipées au pays
il a donc été rapidement désigné par
l'état pour recevoir les personnes
infectées provenant de la région de la
capitale des malades de tous âges des
gens qui ont qui en soi diab est soit
soit à soignies unis mais attention au
matériel donc ce sont en général ces
légendes des personnes que nous
utilisons nous lie désigné pour le
traitement de la cop 19 sont presque
tous occupés
on arrive au point de saturation la
construction de nouvelles unités a été
lancée en urgence dans la cour arrière
de l'hôpital on va faire en sorte qu
l'hôpital puis à roanne capacité des
deux ans les autorités publiques
haïtiennes ont émis une liste de
consignes pour tenter d'enrayer la
transmission on a instauré un couvre feu
de 20h jusqu'à 5 heures du matin et
interdit les rassemblements de plus de
cinq personnes
le port du masque est obligatoire dans
les lieux publics les écoles et la
plupart des commerces restent fermés
manifestement ça ne suffit pas premiers
à monter prendre un arrêté mais elles
s'aiment
2eme 3eme des mômes 4e et des monnaies
mais pam ne pas te faire part pas fait
du jour
ce cordonnier de port au prince âgé de
50 ans dit que toute sa famille porte le
masque et pourtant ils ont contracté le
virus dans son vin et vient quotidien
il constate d'ailleurs que majorité de
gens n'observe pas les consignes pour
gossi d'amanda blizzard d amour par jean
météo et emas nos filles où est dénoncée
la jambe à guin les hôpitaux ne
suffisent plus à la demande des
cliniques privées viennent en renfort le
retour précipité de dizaines de milliers
de haïtiens qui travaillent en
république dominicaine aurait accru la
transmission communautaire
les spécialistes des maladies
infectieuses nous dit qu'elle reçoit
près de 300 patients par jour
infectés par le coronavirus une partie
de son personnel médical est aussi
infectée elle est très inquiète
malheureusement on a hérité fortement
des cas des haïtiens qu'il a pour la
plupart travaillent dans les hôtels
c'est bien connu ou dans les usines et
qui sont arrivés en haïti sans être
triste et et la pathologie s'est propagé
rapidement dans la communauté
le docteur l'aurait adrien est le grand
responsable de la santé publique
haïtienne mandaté pour superviser la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
les seules mesures sur lesquelles on
avait vraiment un contrôle c'est-à-dire
éviter la propagation communautaire à
grande échelle
on n'a pas réussi parce que la
population n'a pas cru dans
l'éventualité de la maladie la
population n'a pas respecté les
consignes
la population ne fait pas tout à fait
confiance à ceux ou à certains qui
portait le message donc voilà nous
sommes là aujourd'hui
la communication représente en soi un
défi dans ce pays miné par la pauvreté
et les expériences et unis de
catastrophe humanitaire a bien frappé
mais décide de sauter verser 6 millions
balaïtous m'a acheté fox et la wii à
kouba forte au cap à bâle
bousquet maillot pour qui jean cointe la
caméra qu'on sache est prêt
même impératif de survie pour cette mère
de famille
comme des milliers d'autres cette mère
de deux enfants est de retour au travail
après un mois d'arrêt forcé usine de
vêtements qui l'emploie a rouvert ses
portes pour fabriquer des masques de
protection et pour permettre à ses 700
employés de toucher un salaire entre le
risque de contracter le virus et celui
de mourir de faim le choix est évident
la peur et les vieilles croyances se
constitue également un obstacle à la
lutte contre la pandémie des hôpitaux
haïtiens antico vide dont celui de
jacmel ont été récemment incendiées ou
vandalisées
la population est mal informée nous dit
ce voisin il ya des gens qu'on a mis des
yodleurs entiers de leurs maisons quand
ils ont su qu'ils ont le corona ils vous
disent que c'est la fièvre
ils vous disent que c'est une tatin de
gilles avec tous ces problèmes combiner
la maladie va continuer de progresser en
haïti nous disent les experts sur place
notre problème spécifique a indiqué que
les jeunes ou épisode d'admettre qu'ils
sont malades vont chercher des sous et
prêta donc il nous faut renforcer la
réponse de tous les départements et ça
c'est un peu lourd financièrement
infrastructures mais aussi pour le pays
il faut rester fort et se battre on
estime que le nombre de cas en haïti
pourrait atteindre prochainement 300
milles avec un taux de décès de 4% soit
un potentiel de 12 mille morts un défi
de plus pour cette population fortement
éprouvée de 11 millions d'habitants